consider the function f of X is equal to
one over x squared minus KX where K is a
nonzero constant the derivative of F is
given by and they give us this
expression right over here it's that's
nice that they took the derivative for
us now Part A let K equals 3 so that f
of X is equal to 1 over x squared minus
3x so they set k equal to 3 write an
equation for the line tangent to the
graph of F at the point whose
x-coordinate is 4 so to find an equation
for line the equation of a line is going
to be of the form y is equal to MX plus
b where m is the slope of the line and B
is the y-intercept and the slope of the
line right over here this is this needs
to be equal to the derivative evaluated
when X is equal to 4 so we could say Y
is equal to let me write it this way we
could say that M is going to be equal to
F prime when X is equal to 4 so F prime
of 4 which is equal to well we know that
K is equal to 3 so they gave us F prime
of X so it's going to be 3 minus 2 times
we're taking F prime of 4 so minus 2
times 4 over x squared so that's going
to be 4 squared minus K is 3 times 4 3
times 4 and then we square that whole
thing and so what is this going to be
this is an 8 right over here and all I
did is F prime of X when K is equal to 3
is going to be 3 minus 2x over x squared
minus 3x and all of that squared and I
want to evaluate what F prime of 4 is so
every place where I saw an X I
substitute it with the 4 where I saw the
K K is 3 and so this is going to be
equal to the numerator is 3 minus 8 is
negative 5 over this is 16 minus 12
which is going to be 4 16 minus 12 is 4
and then we square it so it's going to
be negative 5/16 and so let me write
this way M is equal to negative 5 60
so how do we figure out B now well what
are the coordinates when X is equal to
four what is y going to be equal to well
Y is equal to f of X so we know that Y
on the curve we know that Y is going to
be equal to F of four so before we
evaluate F prime before now we're going
to evaluate Y as being F of four which
is equal to 1 over 4 squared 4 squared
minus three times four and so that is
equal to 1 over 16 minus 12 which is 4
and so this point right here when X is 4
then Y is equal to 1/4 so we can use
that information to solve for B when
when y is 1/4 X so we're going to say if
Y is equal to M which is negative 5 16
negative 5 16 times X well when y is 1/4
X is X or when I say when X is equal to
4 y is 1/4 and then plus B so I can now
solve for B so all I did is I used F
prime of X I used F prime of X to figure
out M when X is equal to 4 and then I
said ok well what is the value of y when
x is equal to 4 and so if I know Y M and
X then I can solve for B and so let's
just do that we get 1/4 is equal to 4
times negative 5/16 is negative 5 over 4
plus B I can add 5/4 to both sides and I
get 5/4 plus 1/4 is equal to B or B is
equal to B is equal to 6 fourths 6 over
4 which you could say well there's a
bunch of ways you could write this we
could just say this is equal to 1.5 and
so our equation is y is equal to
negative 5 over 16x plus 1.5 or if we
wanted to write everything as a fraction
we could say Y is equal to negative 5
over 16x
plus three-halves 6/4 is the same thing
as three as three has and there you go